As I keep saying, as long as you
show up, we'll keep doing it.
So please come over.
Well, for all of you
that were here last week,
you heard an amazing lecture
by Brother Guy Consolmagno,
in which you learned
that we don't
have any clue what life is, but
we put a lot of effort into it.
My favorite definition
is, "You know
it was alive when you kill it."
That was Engels.
I thought that was brilliant.
I want to thank the sponsors
for the lecture series.
That's what allows us all to
come here and enjoy and learn
and be part of a community.
I want, in particular, to thank
Ventana Medical and TEP, which
are the lead sponsors,
but in back of me,
you will see the rest
of the individuals that
make this free for all of us.
And I thank the sponsors
very, very much.
Thank you.
I also want to remind
all of you that this
is a tenth anniversary
of the lecture.
That means that we have a
pile of lectures and podcasts.
And I think you've all seen
looping through the screen
the various lectures that
we've had in the past.
You are welcome
to see the podcast
of all those past lectures.
They're extraordinary.
And you're also welcome,
if you live in a community
where you would like to
have a serious read done
by doing the podcast--
and we've done it
in the past-- we could probably
get a faculty member to show up
after the podcast as
seen by your community
and be there for
questions and answers.
Take that as an invitation
from the College of Science
to continue that.
Today, we're in for a treat.
Let me just share a little
bit, this is a spoiler.
When the earth was formed
about 4.5 billion years ago
as part of the solar
system, it was actually
bombarded by a variety of
comets and Mars-sized objects.
And you can see the evidence of
that, of course, in the moon.
If you look at the moon, you'll
see that it's full of craters.
And the only reason
the earth isn't full
of craters, because it's about
the same age as the moon,
is because it has plate
tectonics and it has erosion
and all of that
old crust is gone.
But the bottom line is
that the earth, when
it was first formed,
was bombarded
by such large impactors that it
partially melted at least once.
And all of the carbon that
was originally on the earth
must have gone
away, because it's
an element that would have
just basically evaporated
off the earth.
One of the ideas, and
that's one of the things
that our speaker today
is going to talk about,
is that carbon from which we
are all made out of perhaps
was implanted in the
earth by later meteorites
or other objects.
The importance about that
is that you should all
remember that, in fact,
we're all Martians.
A little bit about our
speaker today, Dante Lauretta.
We're very fortunate that
Dante is part of our faculty.
Dante actually got his
undergraduate degree here
before he went off to George
Washington University in St.
Louis to get his PhD.
But when he got his
bachelor's here,
it was in physics,
mathematics, and Japanese.
I'm not exactly sure which
was the most important one.
But he then went off
and he came back in 2001
as a faculty member in
the College of Science.
He, together with a team
of planetary sciences
from our distinguished
planetary sciences department,
got an award from NASA
for a billion dollars--
the largest award
this university's ever
had from anybody--
to go and explore
an extraterrestrial object,
collect parts of soil from it,
and bring it back to Earth
so that we can actually
compare the carbon rich material
of these objects to all of us.
It's really, really cool.
Dante is a very
distinguished faculty member.
He just got an award
from Goddard Space Center
for being a team-- that was
the osiris-rex team-- that
was so successful in
getting this grant.
He also got the governor's
innovation award in 2011.
He's gotten awards,
also, for teaching.
Just like most of our
extraordinary faculty members,
he's a triple threat.
He does extraordinary
research and he
does extraordinary teaching.
Please join me in
welcoming Dante Lauretta.
Thank you, Joaquin.
And thank you, everyone,
for coming out tonight.
This is awesome.
You can really tell
that Tucson is a science
city when you get this kind
of crowd for a science lecture
series.
I'm really proud of
you guys and excited
that you're here tonight.
I'm going to take you
on a little journey
to try to understand
how we got to be here.
This is a question that
has driven my career.
To really understand
why is earth so special,
what happened here to give rise
to the earliest life forms,
and how common is that process?
Is it a one in one
trillion chance?
Are we the only
place in the whole
galaxy where this has happened?
Or is it something that
we think might be common
and might be
happening everywhere?
It's one of the most
fundamental questions
that humanity asks itself
is, where did we come from?
And by virtue of that,
where are we going?
So let's go on this
journey and try
to understand the origin of
life, and try to understand,
is that something that's
a natural byproduct
of the formation of planets.
I'm going to take
the approach-- I'm
going to start out by looking
at life on earth today.
This is a fantastic
lecture series
that Joaquin and his team
have put together for us,
because you're going to hear a
wide range of topics that cover
a lot of different approaches.
I'm going to say, well, we
know life exists on Earth.
We can speculate about what
it might be like elsewhere--
and some of our colleagues will
do that-- but I'm going to say,
we know it's here, we want to
understand how it got here.
And so we're going
to first visit
this concept that we call the
last universal common ancestor.
We can go into our
genetic records.
We can go into the
genetic records
of all organisms on Earth.
And we can trace
it back and say,
there was a point in time where
there was one organism that
is the ancestor to everything
else that exists on our planet
today.
We're going to see what
we can learn about that.
And then we're going to
use that to understand
the basic biochemistry of life.
We all share the same molecular
processes in our cells,
between each other, the
other animals, the plants,
the bacteria, the
archaea, et cetera.
So we'll take a look at that.
And then we'll try to
understand, how do you
get the central elements?
As we'll see, there's
really six elements
that are critical for all the
biochemistry that takes place.
Lots of other elements come in.
You've all probably
looked at your Centrum,
seen that big list of elements
that are in your mineral list.
Say, geez, do I really need
that much selenium today?
I don't know.
But we're not going to talk
about the origin of selenium,
we're really going to
take a look at the ones,
the core six, and
how we got here.
Then, how did
these guys combine?
So We can look at the atoms, and
take that atomistic approach,
but it's really the
molecules where things
start to get interesting.
And, where are these
molecules forming?
And then the
astrophysical environments
that lead to the
planet formation
and therefore where the origin
of life proceeded apace.
And then finally, how
did they get from space
to the early Earth?
And what might be going only
on the surface of our planet
that ultimately led this
transition from chemistry
to biology?
Let's go ahead and take
a look at this idea
of the least common ancestor.
Here you have a nice
artistic version
of what we call
the tree of life.
I want to start out
here at the top.
When we look at all the
organisms on the planet,
we can really divide them
up into three major groups.
We have the bacteria, which I
think we're all familiar with.
We have the eukarya, which term
you may not have heard before,
but it really means
organisms that
have a very specific
structure to their cells.
They have a nucleus
and inside that nucleus
is where their DNA
is, the code that
defines that organism
and everything that
happens inside that organism.
And it turns out,
we are the eukarya.
So are all of the animals,
all the plants and a lot
of single-celled
organisms are eukarya.
We all share that
common characteristic
of having the DNA inside
of a nucleus of the cell.
Bacteria don't have that.
DNA floats freely
around in the interior.
And then you get
this interesting one
called the archaea.
It was the last one
to be identified.
They're single celled organisms.
They have a lot of
commonality with the bacteria,
but they share some of the
cell wall characteristics
with the eukarya.
And they really are a different
branch to the tree of life.
So you can see that there is
this complicated evolution
from today.
We can trace back to
a billion years ago.
We can see here, where the
eukarya and the archaea
split from each other, where
the bacteria and the archaea
split from each
other and went down
their own separate
evolutionary pathways.
We get back to this
point, some time
more than three
billion years ago,
where this last common
ancestor existed.
And we say, well, what is
it that all of these share?
You might think, well, I
don't have anything in common
with a palm tree, but you do.
The mechanisms inside your
cells are very, very similar.
The basic biochemistry
of life is
common to all of
those organisms.
Really, what drives us is,
we take these molecules
and we code information.
That information
is inside your DNA.
And DNA is a recipe
book for everything
that has to happen
inside your body.
What it does is it tells
your body and the cells
how do I make proteins.
You need proteins
for your muscles,
you need proteins for your hair.
You need proteins that catalyze
the metabolic reactions that
give you energy and
allow you to be alive.
So if the DNA is the library,
the proteins are the books,
and they go out and they do
all the work inside your body.
The last common
ancestor we think
had this basic
biochemistry established.
It had DNA.
It had genes, which are
the strips of DNA that
code for an individual protein.
And then it used the DNA-- it
has a messenger molecule that's
similar, called RNA,
that leaves the nucleus
of the cell for the eukaryotes
and goes out and builds
the proteins.
All of that has to happen in
a self-contained environment,
and that's what a cell gets you.
It gets you that nice,
chemically-closed system,
where you have membranes for
transporting the species that
are needed inside of there.
We know that that happens
in every cell in our body.
It happens in every
cell on earth,
whether you're bacteria,
eukarya, or archaea.
How do we make that happen?
Well, let's take a look at the
common elements that drive that
and where they come from.
In the beginning, we had this
event we called the Big Bang.
And I was just talking to
a couple of folks about it
right before the
lecture started today,
and people ask me, well, how
do we know that this happened?
Well, it was so big
that we still hear it.
When we look out to the
edge of our universe,
we see this background
radiation, cosmic microwave
background radiation,
which is the energy that
escaped from the Big Bang.
And it's been
propagating through space
for 13.8 billion years.
Well, coming out of
that event, there
was really only two elements--
hydrogen and helium.
Helium, you're probably pretty
familiar with if you've ever
been to a birthday party.
Fills up the balloons.
It's really fun to breathe it
in and talk like Mickey Mouse.
Hydrogen is a common rocket
fuel, very explosive compound.
It mixes with oxygen and
you get that lift off.
But that's not enough
to create life.
In fact, that's not even
enough to create planets.
Pretty much the only
thing in the universe
you can create with these
two elements are stars.
And the stars are
giant nuclear furnaces.
Inside the interior
of the sun, right now,
today, even though
it's nighttime,
the reaction is still going on.
In the core of our sun,
we're taking hydrogen atoms
and we're smashing together
at millions of degrees,
and we're building
helium out of them.
Take four hydrogen, smash
them together, you get helium.
Bigger stars like that process.
They don't want to give up.
The only thing that's
stopping is gravity,
but if gravity can pull
you down tight enough,
if you're a big enough
star, you can actually
cram three helium
atoms together,
and you can get carbon.
And now, you're talking.
Now you're going to get
something interesting going.
You add another
helium, you get oxygen,
and that actually kicks
off a catalytic cycle
we call the
carbon-nitrogen-oxygen cycle,
where the presence of
carbon actually makes
this reaction go a lot faster.
Hydrogen into helium,
and a byproduct of that
is nitrogen. You continue
to add helium atoms
and you'll get up to sulfur.
And I want to stop
here a minute and just
take a look at the atomic
weights of these elements.
You've got helium that's 4.
Carbon, that's 12.
That makes sense,
that's four helium.
Oxygen is 16.
That's-- I'm sorry,
that's three helium.
Oxygen is 16.
Go back here.
Sulfur is 32.
We get over here to
phosphorus, and it's 31.
And that's an odd number
and nuclear reactions
don't like odd numbers.
They don't favor them.
That's going to turn out
to be pretty important.
It's a side chain
reaction, so that
means there's not
a lot of it around
compared to these
other elements.
It's going to become the
limiting nutrient for life
on Earth.
As we'll see, it's
critical and I'll
tell you how we solved
some of that mystery.
The universe took those
hydrogen and helium atoms,
created stars.
The first generation of
stars produced these six
interesting elements.
When you add carbon to
hydrogen, you get hydrocarbons.
You're probably familiar
with these, like natural gas.
Use it to cook with.
Really burns well with oxygen.
You bring in the oxygen,
and now you're getting
carbohydrates and lipids.
We know we like carbohydrates.
They're really tasty.
And the lipids are really
important because that's what
makes up the cell membranes.
Now you're getting some
interesting chemistry,
but you still don't have life.
You bring in nitrogen, and
you get something really cool,
you get the amino acids.
And there's dozens of these
that are produced in nature.
And now you could
build proteins.
You bring in the sulfur.
You get a wider diversity
of amino acids and proteins.
But it's this phosphorous
that needs to kick in order
to get the DNA and RNA.
You won't have
life, you won't have
information-bearing molecules,
at least as we know it,
on this planet unless
that phosphorus gets
into the system.
That was a question very
early on in my career
I was really interested in.
And I'll tell you
why in a little bit.
So now, we know, OK, stars
inside their interiors
are generating energy.
They burn bright.
They give us sunlight.
But they don't live forever.
Nothing in the
universe lives forever.
They're going to burn through
that fuel and at the end,
gravity always wins.
Gravity is just going to
keep crushing you down.
You're going to have
that nuclear energy.
You're going be able to
push them off for a while.
But at the end of
the day, you're
going to run out of fuel, and
gravity is going to take over.
And what happens
is, you get some
of the most energetic
explosions in the universe.
You get supernova, when
the giant stars explode.
What's happening is, we're
in this giant molecular cloud
region here.
And everything's nice and quiet.
You got these really
bright stars burning
through their lifetime, creating
these fundamental elements
that'll go on to create
the biochemical molecules.
But somehow, they got to get
out there and here we go.
We're at the end of
the star's lifetime.
It's trying to hang on.
It goes through
some pulsing phases,
where a little bit more nuclear
fuel gets into its center.
Finally, it's done.
It explodes.
And it throws most of its matter
back out into the universe,
into what we call this
interstellar medium.
Not only is it the
stellar graveyard,
where these giant
stars are running
through their nuclear fuel
and dying and throwing off
everything they
created back out there,
but it's also a stellar nursery.
This is where stars are born.
Same place that these
giant stars are dying.
Now, we can look
at these regions--
and this is one of my favorite
astronomical photographs.
It's actually an infrared
image of the Orion nebula.
Many of you may be familiar
with the Orion constellation,
and this is right in his belt.
With a good pair of binoculars,
you can actually
see this feature.
It turns out, when we
look even farther out
into the infrared, what
we call the far infrared,
or into the microwave,
we see that there's
all kinds of interesting
signals out here.
Every one of these lines
that were showing up
as we scan across these
different wavelengths
are a different molecule.
And we see some really
interesting things.
First of all, you see is
a lot of water out there.
That's good news,
because we think water
is central to life on Earth.
We think it was important fluid
for all of these reactions
to take place.
It's inside our bodies.
It's not a coincidence
that when you cry,
the composition of your tears
is seawater, essentially.
That's where we came from, and
we think it's critical for life
to originate, at least
life as we know it.
But there's a lot of other
things going on here.
You've got methanol, and
you've got formaldehyde,
and you've got deuterium
cyanide, sulfur dioxides.
And a lot of other things.
Like this region
right over here,
there's a lot of
complicated molecules
that are being expressed
in that signal there.
As we go through and we
process this information,
we see there's over
100 different molecules
in these star-forming regions.
Most of them are
organic molecules.
Already, you create
these elements
in the interior of the star,
you throw them off into space,
the whole system cools
down, and the first thing
that nature tries to do is
create organic compounds.
It seems like there's a drive
that's taking place here
to go from the
fundamental process that
drives stellar energy,
turn it into something
else, planetary systems.
We'll take a look at
our own solar system
and say, well, we're looking
out there at the Orion nebula.
We see these stars being born.
What do we think happened
in our solar system?
And we have the
very good fortune
that a lot of
samples from this era
still exist in the
form of our asteroids.
Asteroids are the
geologic remnants
from the earliest stages
of solar system formation.
You want to understand
what the earth was
like when the last universal
common ancestor was wiggling
around 3.8 billion years ago?
Well we don't have a whole
lot of rocks from that era.
You want to know, well,
what happened before that?
What were the earliest phases
of planetary formation?
You have to go to
these meteorites.
Let's take a look.
This is a very special
kind of meteorite called
the carbonaceous chondrites.
It happens to be full of
really interesting inclusions.
First, I want to
draw your attention
to most of the grains in here.
They kind of look rounded like
little grains of sand, maybe.
We call these things chondrules.
And these turn out to be
the fundamental building
blocks of planets.
They're about a
millimeter in size.
Note that this is about 10
centimeters, or just under four
inches across here.
And they record early stages
of planetary formation, where
giant flashes of heat were
propagating through and melting
everything in sight.
They're wildly different
from each other.
We call this an
unequilibrated rock,
which means every chondrule
tells it's own story.
I'll never forget when I first
got one of these meteorites
in the lab and I was
going to study it
and I saw all these great
chondrules, and I said,
I'm going to look at
every one of these.
This is going to be a
great research project.
I'm going to tear
this rock apart.
And two years later, I'd gotten
through about 40 of them.
And I was like, man,
they're all different.
I got to stop.
Right I got to publish
something or else I
won't get this great job at the
U of A that I'm angling for.
But you're like, why are you
talking about those chondrules?
Dude, there's this
giant white inclusion
sitting in the middle
of this rock here.
Take a look at that.
That turns out to be
really fascinating.
It turns out these are what
we call calcium aluminum
rich inclusions, or
calcium aluminum oxides,
and they're what we call
refractory minerals.
For example, we use
these kinds of materials
industrially to make space
shuttle tiles for re-entering
vehicles into the atmosphere.
They survive as solids at
very high temperatures.
And so it's not a surprise
that we see these things
as the oldest minerals, because
the model for solar system
formation is you have this
cloud that's collapsing,
it gets very hot, and then
it starts to cool off.
And so the first things that
condense out like snowflakes
are calcium and
aluminum rich minerals.
It turns out we can go in and
we can take a really good look
at the chemistry
of these objects.
And we can say, well, they've
got some uranium in them.
Uranium is a
radioactive isotope.
We're very familiar with it.
We know how long
it takes to decay.
It takes billions of years
to completely decay away,
and it decays into lead.
We can measure very precisely
the isotopes of uranium
and isotopes of lead, and
we can figure out the age.
These measurements show
us that the solar system
is 4.5 billion years old.
And you probably have
heard that quite a lot.
How do you know the solar
system is 4.5 billion years old?
Well, when I say that,
what I'm really saying is,
I've got these minerals
inside these rocks
that I can date very
precisely with my uranium lead
techniques, and those
are 4.5 years old,
and I haven't found
anything else that's older.
So that's the oldest thing and
all of my ages moving forward
are going to be relative
to that mineral phase.
And that's held up really well.
These things have been
studied for about 40 years now
and we haven't found
anything older.
We find out that they formed
in a very tight window
of about 100,000 years, which
is nothing in the geologic time
scale.
And in fact, the chondrules
are pretty old, as well,
but they formed about two to
four million years after that.
And so we spent a
lot of time trying
to sort out the details
of how these rocks formed.
Where do these things come from?
I told you a little bit
about the model here,
but let's take a look.
Let's go back into
that Orion nebula.
We're going to do a
little fly through here.
Note the four stars
in the center there,
we call those the trapezium.
Those are objects
that are going to go
nova or supernova at the
end of their short lifetime.
You could see their
energy is already
influencing pockets of dust and
gas that's surrounding them.
These little things
that look like
tadpoles-- we call
those proplyds.
This is an actual rendition
of the Orion nebula.
All of these objects
have been identified.
And then we can peer inside one
of these things and say, well,
what's going on in there?
How big is this?
Well, turns out when
we strip away that gas,
we're looking at a new
star that's being born.
And inside Orion, we're looking
at hundreds of new stars
that are being born.
And we see they have
this very common feature,
that the star is forming at the
center, and a disk of material
is spinning out around them.
That actually is a
natural consequence
of a basic physics property
called angular momentum.
We're all familiar with the ice
skater who starts to rotate.
And then as she
pulls her arms in,
she spins faster and faster.
That's due to conservation
of angular momentum.
Well, turns out these clouds,
when they start to collapse,
they have some angular momentum.
There's a net rotation.
And if you try to cram all of
that stuff down to the center
into the star, it
would fall apart.
It would just be too much
of that rotational energy.
So in order to conserve
that angular momentum,
a fraction of the material
doesn't go into the star.
It goes into this surrounding
protoplanetary disk.
That's really good news for
us, because inside that disk
is where all of the
interesting chemistry
takes place that ultimately that
leads to the planetary system
that we know today.
We really see this
process playing out
hundreds of different times
right now in our own galaxy,
in nearby star-forming
regions, and very consistent
with what we know about
our own solar system.
All of the planets line
up in a nice plane.
They're all revolving around
the sun in the same direction.
Most of them are even
rotating about their axis
in the same direction.
It's pretty clear
the planets are
carrying, even today,
all of the angular
momentum in the solar system.
The sun has all the mass.
More than 99% of the mass
ends up in that star,
creating that giant
nuclear furnace.
But that's OK.
We don't need too much.
The 1% is all we need to get by.
We are the 1%.
Let's take a look
inside this cloud.
And we do know that there
are weather storms going on
in here.
You've got all kinds of
flash heating events.
We see those in our chondrules.
A lot of these clips
are from NASA Goddard
and a collaboration
that I did with them
to tell the story of the early
solar system and the asteroid
that we're interested in.
And I was so excited because
for the first time ever,
we animated the process
of chondrule formation.
Bear with me.
What you have is you have
dust bunnies, fine grain dust
particles, that stick together
in the early solar system.
Then these shock waves come
ripping through the gas
and they flash heat these
things to thousands of degrees,
so fast that they create
these molten droplets.
And this process played
out billions of times,
basically creating
little space marbles
that were igneous systems.
These were molten drops of rock
and they slowly crystallize
and those are the building
blocks of planets.
They grow into
asteroid sized objects,
they grow into
mountain-sized objects,
and ultimately they grow
into planet-sized objects.
The chondrules were like that
necessary little stepping
stone.
You had to take the dust,
you had to flash heat it,
you had to accrete
the pebbles together,
and we still have
those samples today.
And every once in a while, I
forget about that, because you
get kind of jaded.
But you stop and you
sit there and you think,
I'm holding a rock that
is older than this planet.
It's the very first thing that
formed that led to the pathway
to planet formation.
This is a really
good thing, right?
Well, yes and no.
That process plays
out, the earth forms.
We think OK.
Well, we're on a pretty good
path to forming life here.
But something odd happened
in the solar system
about 500 million years
after the planets formed.
Something triggered
this giant migration
of the same objects that
built our planets back
into the inner solar system.
We actually think this
was due to Jupiter
being kind of unstable,
and it was slowly
interacting with
Saturn, and then
they hit a critical resonance.
Jupiter got pushed in, so we
think it formed out farther
than it is now, and
then it swung in closer
to the inner solar system.
And it's the most
massive object that we
have except for the sun,
so it has a really strong
gravitational influence.
It basically acted like a
plow-- its gravity field
pushed through the asteroid
belt and flung thousands
of these objects into
the inner solar system,
creating this
period that we call
the late heavy bombardment.
Our planet might have been a
really nice, habitable place
with oceans and organisms
that had originated and were
thriving and living
for 500 million years.
And then sure enough,
thousands of giant impacts
started raining down on
the planetary surface.
Pretty much sterilizing
the entire planet,
evaporating the oceans,
stripping away the atmosphere,
in a period we call
the Hadean, because we
think it was a hot, hellish
environment that anything
would be extremely unlikely
to have survived in.
Now we ask our
questions, well, we're
here, so we know this late
heavy bombardment happened,
we can see it expressed in the
cratering record of our moon.
And in fact, we have a
really good correlation
between the crater
population on the moon
and the size distribution of the
asteroids in the asteroid belt.
That's some research
that was done here
in my home department, the
Lunar and Planetary laboratory,
by one of our other
faculty members.
We know there was this giant
flux of asteroids that smashed
into the surface of the moon.
Anything that hit the moon,
10 times as many of those
would have hit the
surface of the earth.
So we're left with
this molten environment
It's somehow, right
after that period,
we see the first signs of
life showing up on our planet.
Is it a coincidence?
It might be, but it
seems like as soon
as that flux of
massive impactors
ended their reign of terror
on the surface of the Earth,
life showed up.
Either it's somehow survived,
and that's a possibility,
and people explore where would
have been a safe enclave.
Where could life have
survived this process,
a safe harbor that it
could have been crawled out
from afterwards?
Or did, in addition to
reigning that destruction down
on our planet, did
those same objects also
bring in the seeds
of life with them?
One idea, and a very
famous one, coming out
of an experiment called
the Miller Urey experiment,
says those objects
probably would
have ended up bringing in a lot
of what we call reducing gases.
In chemistry, we like to
think about reductions
and oxidations.
When you oxidize
something, you can think
of like burning something.
You're stripping away electrons.
You're reacting with oxygen.
But in a reducing environment,
you wouldn't have the
atmosphere that we have today.
You would have nitrogen,
you might have some water,
you might have methane,
the hydrocarbon, ammonia--
which is key to
those amino acids,
that's where those words
are linked together.
So if you had methane,
and you had ammonia,
and you had some water, and
then you had an lightning storm,
say, Stanley Miller
and Harold Urey
showed that lightning strikes
through such an atmosphere
would actually generate a lot
of really interesting chemistry.
In fact, it would generate
amino acids and nucleic acids
and stuff that we need to build
those critical biomolecules
moving forward.
For a long time,
we said, OK, fine,
all you need are those simple
gases and some weather,
and you can create the basic
building blocks of life.
But we've really dived
into this problem.
We've looked at the geologic
record from this era
and it turns out, it
doesn't look like we
had that reducing atmosphere.
Instead, it looks like we
had more neutral conditions.
We had nitrogen and noble gases.
Things that aren't really going
to react even in a lightning
strike.
And so that put us back
a step, and we said, OK,
we have to think about, if
it's not coming from weather
and energy in our atmosphere
reacting with that very
different composition,
how are we
going to make these key
compounds that go on to build
our critical biomolecules?
I would say, there are
places in the solar system
where this could be happening.
We look at Titan, a
famous moon of Saturn,
and it is draped in a nice
nitrogen-rich atmosphere,
very much like the Earth.
But it also has
a lot of methane,
a very reducing composition.
It also has lakes and oceans.
And so, you'll hear
more about those kinds
of environments in one of the
future lectures in the series.
The other thing we
look at is to say,
we have a geologically
active planet.
We know we must have gotten
this water pretty early on,
and that most likely
came from the asteroids.
A lot of these
asteroids are hydrated.
And that doesn't mean they have
liquid water floating around
them now, but they did at
some point in the past,
and that water reacted with the
rocks and made clay particles.
And clays have water in
their crystal structures.
So you bring those clays
in, they melt and evaporate
in those giant impacts and you
can get a nice liquid ocean
like we have today.
The other thing we have
going on in this planet
is a process called
plate tectonics.
We've got ocean centers
that are spreading.
New oceanic crust is forming.
Old oceanic crust
is subducting down
and the whole crust is getting
recycled over and over again.
You probably didn't
have a lot of continents
at this very early stage, but
you certainly had oceanic crust
and you probably had
spreading centers,
where magma was reaching up
to the bottom of the ocean.
Well, it turns out, that
drives some pretty interesting
processes, because that water
just doesn't stay at the top,
it actually penetrates
deep down into the rocks.
It interacts with
that hot magma.
It boils away and
it comes gushing out
through what we call these
black smoker hydrothermal vents
at the bottom of the ocean.
The reason that they're
black, by the way,
is because they have
lots of sulfide minerals.
That's pretty interesting.
It's interesting to me,
I wrote my PhD thesis
on sulfide minerals.
But it's interesting
in the broader picture
as well, because
sulfide minerals
tend to be really good
catalytic surfaces.
They let chemical reactions
happen that wouldn't otherwise
happen if they weren't there.
Now, you've got all of
this fine grained sulfide
material coming out of
these hydrothermal vents.
You've got liquid water.
And it's thought that
this might be a great site
to catalyze some of
those important reactions
and get the amino acids going.
That's still a
reasonable hypothesis.
The other thought is
that maybe life even
originated before that
late heavy bombardment
and then it was able to hide
out in these hydrothermal vents.
And we go down in
our submersibles
and we look around at
these environments,
and we see they're
teeming with life.
This is miles down the
bottom of the ocean
where no sunlight is reaching.
These are not relying on
photosynthesis or plants
or algae for their
prime energy source.
They're eating the rocks.
They're living on the chemical
energy of these systems.
When we go back to LUCA, our
last universal common ancestor,
we actually say it
looks like it might
be what we call a
thermaphile, which means it
likes really hot temperatures.
We find lots of
thermaphiles coming out
of these black smoker vents
at the bottom of the ocean.
This might be where
our ancestor grew up.
But the other option is
that the asteroids that
brought in the death and
destruction that sterilized
the service of the planet also
brought rebirth and a new start
on life.
Here's a different
meteorite, a different kind
of carbonaceous chondrite.
Similar to the one I showed
you before-- you can even
see some of the white
inclusions that are in there.
We've spent a lot of time
picking through these rocks.
I look at the chondrules, I
look at the sulfide minerals.
But I'm also really interested
in, where's the carbon?
That's what we want to know.
We have a hard time
making carbon minerals
in the early solar system.
Carbon can be stable at
really high temperatures--
you've probably seen graphite
used as a furnace rods
or for high temperature
heating, but that
doesn't work in
our solar system,
because we have too
much oxygen around.
Oxygen likes to grab that
carbon and make gas molecules
like carbon monoxide
and carbon dioxide.
We see carbon way out
in the outer reaches
of our solar system
on the icy planets,
but we don't see a lot
of it in our meteorites,
except these carbonaceous
chondrites might
have a few weight percent
carbon inside of them.
People, even 60
years ago, started
looking at these
things, and they
found some really interesting
compounds, like amino acids
and sugars and alcohols.
We went in and we
found similar things.
We found lots of
different amino acids.
This actually here is the
chemical structure for one
we call isovaline.
You've probably
never heard of it,
because it's not one of
the 20 or 22 amino acids
that our bodies use
to build proteins.
In fact, that's the
reason we study it,
because we don't have to worry
about it being contaminated
by biological organisms.
It turns out, not only
do meteorite scientists
like these rocks, but
bacteria like them as well.
As soon as they get onto
the surface of the Earth,
they're immediately
colonized by bacteria,
who start to eat away all
of the great scientific data
that's inside of them.
We're rushing against them to
try to get that information out
before it's all gone.
We can go in and we
can say, well, they're
not going to eat
isovaline, because they
can't use it to make proteins.
So we can study it and we can
try to understand its chemical
properties.
And it turns out, when you look
at proteins and amino acids,
there's two different versions
of the same amino acid,
isovaline has a
right-handed version
and it has a
left-handed version.
We call this enantiomers
of each other, which
means they're
chemically identical,
but they're just mirror
images of each other.
You can't look on the back
side, and it won't-- it'll look
different, because of the way
that atoms are arranged inside
of there.
When we look at the
amino acids that
are in our proteins
in our bodies,
life exclusively uses the
left-handed amino acids.
No right-handed people allowed,
no right-handed proteins
allowed, all of your
proteins are sinister.
We say, well, that's
pretty interesting.
What if we look at the
enantiomeric distribution
of these non-biologic amino
acids in the carbonaceous
chondrites?
We know they came
from the meteorites,
we know the meteorite
came from outer space.
And so it turns
out, when we look--
we looked at a whole
range of these rocks.
Many of them which had
been altered by that water
that I talked about,
ice had probably
accreted into the asteroid
early in its history,
and then melted and
changed the chemistry
and the mineralogy quite a bit.
But when we look at the ones
that have no or minimal water
exposure, we see that there
is an excess of about 60%--
out of 260 molecules, 160 would
be left-handed and 100 would be
right-handed.
That's pretty interesting,
because now we say, well, we
know that these rocks are
falling on the earth today.
We know these rocks are
4.5 billion years old.
So they were certainly
falling on the earth
3.8 or 4 billion years ago when
that late heavy bombardment was
winding down.
And they're bringing in a
handedness to the molecules
that life seems to prefer.
I think you can make
a really strong case
that the origin
of life was likely
catalyzed by these
objects falling
onto the surface of our planet.
But then you've got to put
all the pieces together.
And I want to bring us back now
to that element phosphorous,
because that's the one
that's really tricky.
Some of the work that I
did early on in my career
here in the early 2000s
through about 2006
really focused on this process.
We found something
really, I thought,
amazing-- it was one of those
great moments in science
where you do a very
simple experiment
and the results are
profound, and you
know your career has been
worth it up to that point.
We've been looking in those
carbonaceous chondrites
for a long time, because we know
there's amino acids in there,
there's sugars in there,
there's nucleic acids in there,
and if we could just
find this phosphorus,
we could think about how
we're going to make that DNA,
because DNA needs
the phosphorus.
It in fact makes the backbone.
When you see that
double helix of DNA,
the spine on either side of
it is a sugar phosphate chain,
and the nucleic acids
hang off the side of that,
and that's where the information
is to code your proteins.
But all of the
minerals that contain
phosphorus in the carbonaceous
chondrites were really boring.
They didn't want to
react with anything.
We were trying to put him
through all these chemical
processes, the same
processes that we
think are altering
the amino acids,
and they're just sitting there.
And they're not changing.
And my graduate
student's starting
to get desperate-- just
give me a thesis topic,
I'll do anything.
And I said, well, a
lot of different things
are falling on the earth.
Maybe we're thinking
too much about
these carbonaceous chondrites.
And I said, there's
some pretty interesting
phosphorous minerals
in iron meteorites.
Here, you're looking at
a slab of iron meteorite.
I could hold it in my hands.
It's about five or six
inches across here.
I said, look at this shooting
star right here in the slab.
This is a mineral we
call schreibersite,
it's a phosphorus-bearing
mineral,
but unlike the phosphates, which
are the most abundant phase
in you're carbonaceous
chondrites,
these are a phosphide,
very different chemistry.
Here, you've got Fe3P,
no oxygen around,
and I said, well, you know iron
meteorites, when they come in,
they come in big.
We've got iron meteorites that
are 60 tons in size sitting
on the surface of the Earth.
There's a lot of
these guys, and these
are coming from
the ancient cores
of differentiated planets.
Basically, you had an asteroid
they got big enough that
completely melted, and
all of the iron and nickel
and phosphorous and other
metals sank to the center,
and all of the oxygen
and magnesium and silicon
that make up most of the
rocks stayed in the mantle
or even erupted as
volcanoes onto the crust.
I said, but these
guys get shattered
in giant catastrophic
collisions in the asteroid belt
and they come raining
down onto the planet
just like the carbonaceous
chondrites do.
And I bet something
pretty interesting
happens when a reduced
phase like that hits water.
We saw-- like I said,
one of the great moments
of my scientific career-- a
very, very simple experiment,
take iron phosphite and
drop it in a glass of water,
and come back in
a couple of days
and run it through some fancy
chemical analysis equipment.
And we say, over here
there are the phosphates.
These are the kinds of things
that make up our DNA and RNA,
and this is what the
minerals are made out of.
And this guy, you can see, it's
the end of this reaction chain.
We were trying to
start here, and we
wanted things like this
triphosphonate is like ATP.
This is your energy
source in your cells here.
We couldn't get these reactions
to go this way or over here,
so you could start adding more
interesting chemical compounds
like nucleic acids to them.
Well, turns out, when
you've got a metal that's
an oxidation state of 0 and
phosphates sitting over here
at plus 5, and so, you don't
make this immediate leap
over here to phosphate.
In fact, you go to plus 3 and
you make this phosphonate.
What's important here is, you
see the phosphorus is purple
and the oxygen is red, all
of your phosphorus bonds--
there's five of them,
there's a double bond
there-- all of the phosphorus
bonds are taken up by oxygen,
so nothing else interesting
is going to happen there.
Over here, you've got a bond
with this white ball, which
is hydrogen, and
that can go on and do
all kinds of cool things.
Turns out, you can't just
jump over here to the plus 4,
you need to bring two
of these guys together.
And then you can
do a back reaction.
And then you can get
all the way down here
to this triphosphonate.
So I said, I think this is
something really important.
Matt Pasic was my graduate
student who worked on this.
We published this paper in 2005.
And he's made his career
on this discipline now.
He's studying how reduced
phosphorus minerals
may have contributed
to the origin of life.
Going on for a decade now.
He's been very successful at it.
Really exciting.
Kind of a hybrid model.
We think the nucleic
acids and the amino acids
probably came in the
carbonaceous chondrites,
but then you had to have
this giant iron meteorite
land in an aqueous environment.
And the good news
is, because they're
so big they corrode
away very slowly.
Iron meteorites might be around
for hundreds of thousands
of years.
You've got this
nice, steady supply
of highly reactive phosphorus
compounds coming out
into your aqueous system, maybe
even those hydrothermal vents,
where they can
participate in that party,
and get going with
those sulfide minerals,
and create all the
interesting chemistry that's
going to lead to biomolecules.
What we've got here is, going
back to getting to LUCA,
we know we can start out
with these interesting small
compounds.
Here is the nucleic
acids that make up RNA.
We can go ahead and
bring in those phosphates
and through these
aqueous reactions
get our sugar
phosphate background.
And now you've got an
information-bearing molecule.
So we've got a long way
towards the origin of life.
And then ultimately, we've got
to make this step to a living
cell, and I'll admit we
haven't got there yet.
We haven't had an
independent origin
of life in our
laboratories on earth yet.
But I don't think
that's too far away.
It's still one of the
great mysteries of science,
and it's still driving
a lot of what we do.
In fact, we are a
little bit frustrated
with the meteorite analysis.
I mentioned those bacteria
getting in my rocks,
ruining a lot of stuff.
So I said, fine,
I'm going to go out
and I'm going to
get some of my own,
and you're not going to be
allowed to play with it.
I think we can really say
that this life on earth
came along for the ride through
this whole process of star
formation, of planet
formation and accretion
in our protoplanetary disks.
And that the basic
building blocks of life,
they seem to be pretty common.
We see them in star forming
regions in abundance.
And now we're finding
all these crazy planets
around other stars-- we call
these the extra solar planets.
And one of the other
lectures in our series
is going to talk
to you about these.
My guess is, the basic
building blocks of life
are widespread in
planetary systems.
And that the chemistry
that has taken place here
has probably played
out millions of times
elsewhere in our galaxy.
But we're going to go.
We're going to keep
going on this adventure.
We're going to keep pursuing
these scientific questions.
We're going to do it
in a very big way.
What you're hearing
tonight is really
just the prelude to what's
going to be happening right here
in Tucson starting next year.
I want you guys to come
with me on this ride.
I'm leading a program called
the osiris-rex asteroid sample
return mission.
We are very busy at work
building a robot that we
are going to put on top of a
giant column of explosives,
and on September
3rd, 2016, we're
going to light that
candle up, and we're
going to throw this
robot into outer space.
He's going to cruise
through outer space
for two years to rendezvous
with a giant mountain
of carbonaceous
chondrite material.
And we're going to spend
about a year surveying it
in great detail.
We're going to do
things that have never
been done before, we're
going to map it's chemistry
and mineralogy across the
entire surface of the asteroid.
It's about 500 meters
or 1,800 feet tall,
about the size of Push Ridge.
We're going to
start to get really
interested on certain
spots on the surface, where
we're ultimately going to do
some low altitude flyovers.
We're going to investigate
these areas in great detail.
And then I'm going to make
the call, "go", "no goo".
And when it's "go",
we're going to deploy
a robotic arm that's about three
meters long, nine feet long.
This will be 2019.
It'll be 15 years after I
started on this project.
It'll be after we've spent about
a billion of US taxpayer money.
We're going to take this
perfectly good satellite,
and we're going to fly it into
the surface of an asteroid.
We're going to do what we
call a touch and go maneuver.
We're going to make contact with
that asteroid surface for five
seconds.
We will have spent 15
years planning and building
this system.
We're going to set a
giant air filter down
on the surface, which
would be perfectly happy
on the carburetor of 56 Chevy.
We're going to open up a bottle
of gas, nitrogen in this case,
and we're going to blow
it down into the surface
of that asteroid.
And that's going to agitate
the gravel and the dust
that makes up the
surface of this object,
and that filter is
going to catch it.
And then we're going to
get out of the Dodge,
because the asteroid
is probably going
to throw a bunch of that
stuff back up towards it.
We're going to check it out.
When we think we've got
sample in that filter,
we're going to open
up a return capsule,
and we're going to
place it in the center.
We're going to take
some pictures to make
sure everything looks good.
And then we're going to remove
the arm, leave the head behind.
We're going to
button up, and we're
going to spend 2.5
years coming back home.
2.5 years later, we're going
to spin that capsule up,
and we're going to drop it
into the top of the atmosphere
at 28,000 per hour.
Most of that energy will be
dissipated by the heat shield.
We're using a proven design.
Here's actually the Stardust
sample return capsule
coming in.
It's targeting the
Utah Test and Training
Range to the southwest
of Salt Lake City.
We'll open up a
couple of parachutes.
In 2023, on September
24th, that capsule
will be opened at the
NASA Johnson Space Center
in Houston, Texas, and
20 years of my career
will end with this
scientific treasure.
No bacteria allowed.
Thank you.
So please, come with us.
I really want Tucson
to celebrate this.
It's all happening about
two miles up the road
in the Michael J.
Drake building.
And I want this
town-- I want it to be
as excited as when the
Wildcats make the final four.
This is a big deal.
I want to thank a
couple of people.
We've had a great team working
on this Life in the Universe
series.
Next week, you've got
a great talk coming up,
I hope you're all here to see
Brian Enquist talk about Life
on Earth, By Chance or By Law.
I want to thank Ken [? Godat ?]
and Carl [? Philbond ?]
for helping me prepare the
presentation for you tonight.
And I want to thank Joaquin Ruiz
for getting us all together.
Great things happen when
you put people in a room
together to focus
on a common idea.
I want to thank
the Galileo Circle
for all of their great support.
I want to thank all of you
guys for coming out tonight.
It's really-- I've
had a great time.